[Music]
when their respective escorts had
withdrawn to an equal distance the two
leaders advanced to meet each other each
accompanied by an interpreter the
greatest commander's not only of their
own age but of all who are recorded in
history before their day the peers of
the most famous kings and commanders
that the world had seen
[Music]
for a few moments they gazed upon one
another in silent admiration Hannibal
was the first to speak if he said
destiny has so willed it that I who was
the first to make war on Rome and who
have so often had their final victory
almost within my grasp should now be the
first to come to ask for peace I
congratulate myself that fate has
appointed you above all others as the
one from whom I am to ask it amongst you
many brilliant distinctions this will
not be your smallest title to fame that
Hannibal to whom the gods have given the
victory over so many Roman generals has
yielded to you that it has fallen to
your lot to put an end to a war that has
been more memorable for your feats than
for hours
this is indeed the irony of fortune that
after taking up arms when your father
was consul and having him for my
opponent in my first battle it should be
his son to whom I come unarmed to ask
for peace it would have been far better
had the gods endowed our fathers with
such a disposition that you would have
been contented with the sovereignty of
Italy whilst we were contented with
Africa as it is even for you Sicily and
Sardinia and no adequate compensation
for the loss of so many fleets so many
armies and so many splendid generals
but it is easier to regret the past than
to repair it we coveted what belonged to
others consequently we had to fight for
our own possessions not only as war
assailed you in Italy and us in Africa
but you have seen the arms and standards
of an enemy almost within your gates and
on your walls while we here in Carthage
the murmur of the Roman camp so the
thing which we detest most of all which
you would have wished for before
everything has actually come about the
question of peace is raised when your
fortunes are in the ascendant we who are
most concerned in securing peace are the
ones to propose it and we have full
powers to treat whatever we do here our
governments will ratify all we need is a
temper to discuss things calmly as far
as I'm concerned coming back to a
country which I left as a boy years and
a checkered experience of good and evil
fortune have so disillusioned me that I
prefer to take reason rather than
fortune as my guide as for you your
youth and unbroken success will make you
I fear impatient of peaceful counsels it
is not easy for the man who thought you
never deceives to reflect on the
uncertainties and accidents of life
well I was at thrush menace and Atkin a
that you are today you are hardly old
enough to bear arms when you were placed
in high command and in all your
enterprises even the most daring fortune
has now played you false you avenge the
deaths of your father and your uncle and
that disaster to your house became the
occasion of your winning a glorious
reputation for courage and filial piety
he recovered the lost provinces of Spain
after driving for Carthaginian armies
out of the country then you were elected
consul and whilst your predecessors had
hardly spirit enough to protect Italy
you crossed over to Africa and after
destroying two armies and capturing and
burning two camps within an hour taking
the powerful monarchs syphax prisoner
and robbing his dominions and hours of
numerous cities you have at last dragged
me away from Italy after I had kept my
hold upon it for 16 years it is quite
possible that in your present mood you
should prefer victory to an equitable
peace I too know the ambition which aims
at what is great rather than that what
is expedient on me to a fortune such as
yours once shown but if in the midst of
success the gods should also give us
wisdom we ought to reflect not only what
has happened in the past but also on
what may happen in the future
to take only one instance I myself am
sufficient example of the fickleness of
fortune only the other day I had placed
my camp between your city and the a neo
and was advancing my standards against
the walls of Rome here you see me
bereaved of my two brothers brave
soldiers and brilliant generals as they
were
front of the walls of my native place
which is all but invested and begging on
behalf of my city that it may be spared
the fate with which I have threatened
yours the greater a man's good fortune
the less he ought to count on it
success attends you and has deserted us
and this will make peace all the more
splendid to you who grant it to us who
asks for it it is a stern necessity
rather than an honorable surrender peace
once established is a better and safer
thing than hoping for a victory that is
in your hands this is in the hands of
the gods do not expose so many years
good fortune to the haphazard of a
single hour you think of your own
strength but think too of the path that
fortune plays and the even chances of
battle on both sides there will be
swords and Men to use them nowhere does
the event less answer expectation than
in war victory will not add so much to
the glory which you can now win by
granting peace as defeat will take away
from it the chances of a single hour can
annihilate all the honors you have
gained and all you can hope for
if you cement a peace P Cornelius you
are master of all otherwise you will
have to accept whatever fortune a God
send you em at Ilyas Regulus on this
very soil would have afforded an almost
unique instance of the success which
waits on merit had he in the hour of
victory granted peace to our fathers
when they asked for it but as he would
set no bounds to his prosperity no curb
his elation
that his good fortune the height to
which he aspired only made his fall the
more terrible it is for him who grants
peace not for him who seeks it to name
the terms but perhaps it may not be
presumptuous in us to assess our own
penalty we consent to everything
remaining yours for which we went to war
Sicily Sardinia Spain and all the
islands that lie between Africa and
Italy we Carthaginians confined within
the shores of Africa are content since
such is the will of the gods
to see you ruling all outside our
frontiers by sea and land as your
dominions I am bound to admit that the
lack of sincerity lately shown in the
request for peace and in the non
observance of the truce justified your
suspicions as to the good faith of
Carthage
but skippy o the loyal observance of
peace depends largely upon the character
of those through whom it is sought I
hear that your Senate have sometimes
even refused to grant it because the
ambassador's are not of sufficient rank
now it is Hannibal who seeks it and I
should not ask for it if I did not
believe it to be advantageous to us and
because I believed it to be so I shall
keep it in violet as I was responsible
for beginning the war and as I conducted
it in a way which no one found fault
with until the gods were jealous of my
success so I shall do my utmost to
prevent anyone from being discontented
with the peace which I shall have been
the means of procuring
to these arguments the Roman commander
made the following reply
I was quite aware Hannibal that it was
the hope of your arrival that led the
Carthaginians to break the truce and
cloud all prospect of peace
in fact you yourself admit as much since
you are eliminating from the terms
formerly proposed all that has not
already been long in our power however
as you are anxious that your countrymen
should realize what a great relief you
are bringing them I must make it my care
that they shall not have the conditions
they formerly agreed to struck out today
as a reward for their perfidy you do not
deserve to have the old proposals still
open and yet you are seeking to profit
by dishonesty our fathers were not the
aggressors in the war for Sicily no
where we the aggressors in Spain but the
dangers which threatened our Mamet ein
allies in the one case and the
destruction of Sag anthem in the other
made our case a righteous one and
justified our arms that you provoke the
war in each case you yourself admit and
the gods bear witness to the fact they
guided the former war to a just and
righteous issue and they are doing and
will do the same with this one
as for myself I do not forget what weak
creatures we men are I do not ignore the
influence which fortune exercises and
the countless accidents to which all our
doings are liable had you of your own
free will evacuated Italy and embarked
your army before I self Africa and then
come with proposals for peace well I
admit that I should have acted in a
high-handed and arbitrary spirit if I
had rejected them but now that I dragged
you to Africa like a reluctant and
tricky defendant I am not bound to show
you the slightest consideration so then
if an addition to the terms on which
piece might have been concluded
previously there is the further
condition of an indemnity for the attack
on our transports and the ill treatment
of our invoice during the armistice I
shall have something to lay before the
councils if you consider this
unacceptable then prepare for war as you
have been unable to endure peace
thus no understanding was arrived at and
the commander's rejoined their armies
they reported that the discussion had
been fruitless that the matter must be
decided by arms and the result left to
the gods
[Music]
[Music]